don't even know anymore up figured out I
ain't gonna go to college Lee Corso
no girls but I never kept the door
closed once one either way I put it in
there we got the homies this is a he's
pretty much the biggest rapper on the
planet right now
Mac Miller what's up man bro hey man is
this the first time you've been in Las
Vegas it is bro really yeah man I know
now why you took an off day on the tour
I know going in I had to get with the
daiquiri I know again the night start
right now I feel like this is the start
of the hangover movie like we drink
Group a curries I didn't I wake up like
butt-ass naked on top set your night off
right man hopefully it'll be a memorable
night oh dude album came out booth like
all right you got it
I had to buy it man I had him I had to
go to zero records and copy my copy on
Tuesday dude I just read online it
projected to be number one on the charts
brother oh man that's a first
if it happens I want to jinx myself but
if it would happen that I had number one
which the projections are saying that
that's gonna have him if I do hear
number one I'll be the first independent
release number one since our count dogs
that's what's crazy crazy dude that's
the only other one ever I wanted to ask
you cuz man I know that
trying to sign you or just probably
still trying to sign you I know
Drake had our opportunity they kind of
do what you're doing whiz you know could
have probably did something similar with
his buzz I mean but you stuck with it
you're independent still what what made
you
I guess not sign and just you know keep
it keeping in d-man because how much
cooler do I look right now
a lot cool fill me tho your pockets are
looking a lot cooler too but like that's
the thing but to be real man it's just
you know cool to put on for the
independent game right now because
there's a lot of dope people making
music who are independent artists and
you know being that if we had number one
and we're on top of the charts at an
independent artist then maybe you know
that gives people the incentive to
really look what the independent game
has you know like there's a lot of
people that are doing things
independently and the other thing is I
just I'm trying to be a boss of my own
[__] man like I want to I want to be
able to decide what goes down right I
want to know everything I want people to
run things by me before they go out I
don't want to be part of a major label
sit there and wake up and there's like a
whole line of you know Mac Miller baby
bottles and I didn't even know was out I
got you so I'm just trying to you know
really keep it within the family and
have all my people have jobs and all
that [__] so the projected numbers I saw
some numbers some I saw some tweets
180,000 and I saw a hundred thousand
either way it looks like you're gonna
push over a hundred thousand units yeah
think how crazy I remembered like seeing
your kool-aid and frozen pizza a video
on rap radar no no now that was like
what a year and a half ago it seems like
it was uh it was that came out in early
August of 2010
you know I was about thinking a little
bit over a year ago and that was like
your that was pretty much her first like
no ma'am
well no I'm saying was that like your
first major look on the block oh yeah no
the first see when we put out lalalala
by the way it was Q's idea to add that
extra live because he said everyone has
lalala so we needed for loss but um yeah
blast it out and I was like when I first
got on the blogs and you know people
really started getting a look at me but
I have been putting out mixtapes for
like perhaps three years prior to that
that's what something it well it's been
a long journey um I know your fans are
crazy loyal they are wondering what do
you attribute to that I mean that I know
I see you doing like the you streams
which I check out the one that you were
talking about all right if I sell you
did the presale like 5,000 25,000
you know we go we're gonna do this buy
it you know I think it was a hundred
thousand put it out yeah cuz I mean cuz
if we had a hundred we didn't write if
we would have had a hundred thousand
it's like you put that out well I get
twenty five thousand right yeah we hit I
think the final tally was like forty one
thousand Brazil which is crazy man like
that's like major artists numbers like
the the craziest part of everything is
that on the numbers and all the
statistics shown you know you would
think that there's a secret major label
but I put it on my grandpa's grave that
there's no major there's no major health
nothing because I have heard people say
are not landing exactly that's what I'm
saying like they want it cuz they don't
understand what I use credit because
they're like they're like Mac Miller's
wack men these other people are better
and and why aren't they as puffin you
know but it's like man look man we're
independent
we've always been independent and we
will continue to be for as long as
possible and I think somebody you and I
think a lot of the newer artists are are
kind of you guys are going on footwork
man you guys are really building your
fan base the right way you know he
reckoning gonna tell records right it'll
sell you know it'll sell single it maybe
but you know you ain't gonna be able to
push on it down in Union right because
you're not making it
hang on a day-to-day basis right like
the coolest thing that I've seen by far
is that I get twit pics and people
tweeting me and sending me pictures of
them holding like five albums like I'm
saying like my fans are going out and
it's not just about getting the album
like to them they want to see us give
this new number of likes they want to
see because they're part of it so it's
like they buy that home on iTunes then
they go buy it on iTunes again off their
mom's crater and then they go to the
store and buy three of them because they
want to see this work
I wouldn't bought the album and there's
some of my heart like I am a Kanye Stan
but I did not buy watch the throne
I like support like you know I wouldn't
bought technology like I was like man
this is something special so you know I
had to buy this apartment but you know
they're you know this day I don't see
this happening for a long time crazy now
right second I was dope you know that me
a shout-out tec-9 too because he's like
you know the independent the independent
kingpin right you know I'm saying he's
got the whole headquarters and
everything and he's got a whole label
and he's killing it you know so why not
tec-9 his dope to seem you know both of
us kind of like on top of the hip-hop
charts right now um the thing that drew
me to you man was I'm like a super
hip-hop head man and you have always you
know the record that really got for me
was the nikes on my feet with the non
sample yeah a man is official there are
young dudes are like how did you I mean
coming up I mean 50 cent was popping in
you know what I'm saying right um what
point of time did you like tell like get
that knowledge I guess it's just my
homies we're always older than me Gramps
and and having the internet at my you
know saying that my whatever the word is
disposable disposal Thank You bootleg
man I appreciate that but look having
any of my disposal um saying I'm able to
I'm able to go in research you know as
fifteen year old kid I was able to go
find you know Big Al records and NAS
records and Tribe Called Quest records
and old al cast records although the
first album I think that I ever owned
because I stole it off my brother was
Outkast equipment on it
no that's one of my favorite albums ever
that's what it L one right that's a
great horse out plan that it was really
in sync now you always hear you talking
about bingo bingo is he's one of my
favorite rappers definitely you know if
he was still alive I think he'd be up
there I mean he was about to he was
about to say what's your like favorite
big out punchline man I don't want to
say you know SP Misaka never ahead yeah
but that's just like that's so crazy man
um I mean I think like I like I mean my
favorite is I know a lot of this will
get bleeped out but the [__] type I've
disliked I'm rougher than a fistfight
all chicks a [__] ain't no such thing as
miss right so we can never be a couple
hunt
oh you don't love all I got four girls
it's hard dick and bubblegum yes yes yes
that's what it is mango in the building
do go when I'll be cleaning up record
for Big Al records when I first started
doing my underground hip-hop show is the
most frustrating oh hey man Freddie
Gibbs my god because it's so much but I
wanted to ask you man I saw you got real
choked up man when you were doing that
Hummer these party y'all yeah it's crazy
dude I mean you deserve you know like
like I said you've done a lot footwork
in the last year and ahead it seems like
you blown up in such a small amount of
time now anytime that happens anybody
asking your favorite part of loominatee
yet have you gotten the upload of course
thinks I'm in the Illuminati bro they're
like look at the triangles on his album
Illuminati look at him in a freak Park
market video he he holds the the glass
over his eyes Illuminati like man if I
was in a Lincoln never do for you
successful in rap right you're in the
alone now you can't just like have a
tight street team and be going hard
you're in the Illuminati no I mean if I
was in the Illuminati man I would be
pissed at them because I don't have
enough to be your father the Illuminati
got extra day like some Ferraris and
everything we have Jets I don't got any
of that yet man so if I was in
loominatee I would be I would be in this
interview with a fur coat and a cane and
a tip goblet beautiful hey now we talked
to you said earlier you're a richest
[__] which I definitely I definitely do
not want a question have you made a big
purchase yet man oh now you see a real
money yeah I mean I'm about to I I got a
Benz okay
that was kind of a I got the e350 okay
okay I'm saying slow-mo something but
not man I'm not like the big crazy
spending type dude I like the what eats
my pockets is like spending money on
like fun I'm saying it when we go to the
club like buying bottles for everyone
and just like having a good time like
having hella crazy meals but Lima 2 out
here yeah I would not think I would go
broke out here ghost I have a feeling if
you help me y'all make it to the strip
club while you're out here they're
legendary Spearmint Rhino back to the
Spearmint Rhino man that sounds like a
sex position it was like the Olympics
for